[Música]
hace tiempo américa del sur viví
armoniosamente junto a áfrica hasta que
una grieta en la tierra dividió los dos
continentes hace 200 millones de años
durante la separación del
supercontinente conocido como pangea su
proximidad en aquel entonces explica por
qué los mismos fósiles de plantas y
reptiles se encuentran en la costa este
de américa del sur y en la costa oeste
de áfrica sin embargo esta evidencia no
explica cómo se separaron los
continentes para eso examinamos la
tierra bajo nuestros pies aunque quizá
no lo notemos el suelo viaja a través de
la tierra a una velocidad de 10
centímetros al año oa la velocidad a la
que crecen las uñas
el movimiento ocurre en las capas
superiores del manto terrestre la
litosfera y la aste noosfera la
litosfera que incluye la corteza y el
manto superior comprende la tierra que
nos rodea debajo está la tecnosfera la
porción de roca viscosa pero sólida del
manto superior está entre 80 y 200
kilómetros debajo de la suba
de la tierra mientras la atmósfera
envuelve el núcleo de la tierra como una
región conectada la litosfera se divide
en placas tectónicas hay siete placas
tectónicas principales que componen la
forma del planeta actual al igual que
las otras placas tectónicas más pequeñas
las principales tienen 100 kilómetros de
espesor y se componen de una o dos capas
la corteza continental y la oceánica la
corteza continental forman los
continentes y las costas mientras que la
corteza oceánica forman las cuencas
oceánicas la transición de la corteza
continental granítica a la corteza
oceánica basáltica se produce más allá
de la plataforma continental cuando la
costa desciende hacia el fondo del
océano
la placa de américa del sur es un
ejemplo de una planta tectónica formada
por dos cortezas el continente que
conocemos y una gran región del océano
atlántico circundante estas placas
forman la litosfera y son más frágiles y
rígidas que la capa caliente y maleable
de la atmósfera
gracias a esto las placas tectónicas
flotan encima de esta capa
independientemente una de otra
la velocidad y la dirección en que se
mueven estas placas dependen de la
temperatura y la presión de la atmósfera
de abajo algunos científicos todavía
están tratando de determinar que produce
este movimiento y unas teorías apuntan a
la convección del manto otros examinan
la influencia de la rotación terrestre y
la atracción gravitatoria debido a que
estas placas tectónicas se están
moviendo y lo han hecho durante miles de
millones de años se producen muchos
tigres y aflojes entre ellas el primer
tipo de interacción es un límite
divergente en el que dos placas se
alejan esto lo vemos en la dorsal del
atlántico medio entre américa del sur y
áfrica la próxima interacción es cuando
chocan dos placas el límite convergente
en este caso la tierra es empujada hacia
arriba para formar grandes cadenas
montañosas como el himalaya
de hecho la placa india sigue chocando
con la placa euroasiática por lo que el
monte everest crece un centímetro por
año por último están los límites de
transformación
dos placas se rozan la fricción del
límite de transformación lleva a muchos
terremotos que es lo que sucede en los
1300 kilómetros de largo de la falla de
san andrés el movimiento de la tierra es
imparable y si bien un desplazamiento de
10 centímetros por año puede no parecer
mucho durante millones de años nuestro
planeta seguirá cambiando drásticamente
de hecho un mapa proyectado muestra las
ciudades de los ángeles y san francisco
una encima de la otra quizá a américa
del sur y áfrica se reunirán de nuevo
también solo el tiempo lo dirá